yes I've been producing this video
commentary on Hegel's phenomenology one
of the things that I haven't been doing
typically in transitioning from major
section of the work to make your section
of the work for instance from
consciousness to self-consciousness is
pausing and rather than talking about a
particular paragraph talking about the
whole of that section but I think that
that's really warranted here as we move
into the reason section and there's
there's several good reasons why that
should be the case one is if you if you
notice how much material were actually
actually covering in this where we're
going through more than 200 paragraphs
the three largest sections of the work
still lie ahead of us that would be the
longest or the spirit and then reason
and then religion we have gone through a
lot of material we've actually made it
through a little under one third of the
entire text of the phenomenology but we
still have the majority of our work
lying ahead of us that might be seen as
bad news to some people especially if
you made it this entire way it's almost
like a marathon but it's also good news
in that as we're going into these other
sections things actually become a bit
more concrete and it's a little bit
easier to identify what's being talked
about with particular social or
historical dynamics Hegel still doesn't
mention a lot of things by name doesn't
give you any footnotes so we have to do
some filling in the gaps but it is much
easier to do it I think in these
sections to come so we're going into a
really long and large session where
we've crossed over from
consciousness and self-consciousness and
everything that's been developed in
those two now this juncture point where
self-consciousness has become aware of
itself as a unique individual through
this process of mediation that we saw at
the end of the only happy consciousness
and as we're going to see the Hegel is
going to now start talking in terms of
idealism and telling us what idealism in
his view is supposed to mean because
there are other idealists who Hegel does
not agree with what I wanted to do here
I thought it might be most useful to do
is to talk a little bit about the title
and the organization of this section so
what we're doing is some very very high
you know five mile up looking down he
calls this the the certainty and truth
of reason right the next section is just
gonna be called spirit but this one is
about these themes that we seem coming
up over and over again certainty and
truth we arrive at the end of
self-consciousness at a point where it
looked like at least for some son being
the mediator it was in and for itself in
an attained to both certainty and truth
and that's something that we see as a
theme over and over again in Hegel's
work you have you know certainty but you
don't yet have truth so you you do your
work to try to get the truth and in the
process almost sort of like somebody
who's you know continually picking one
thing up and putting another thing down
or you know losing track of what's going
on over here because their attention is
over here you gave the truth and then
you know the question is is that truth
certain and you get to go back and forth
now it's not just a ever repeating cycle
instead it's it's essential or you can
think of it as some commentators that
said and sort of say coital or spiraling
in closer and closer and closer and what
are we getting closer to on the one set
I'm running on the absolutes the the
entire system on the other hand
the concrete experience that we
ourselves are enmeshed with them so
we're going to still be working out the
certainty and truth of self
consciousness as reason he's got this
broken down into three sections and or
three parts rather one of the things I
want to say is that traditionally when
we have talked about reason in
philosophy many philosophers like to
make a distinction between two
employments of reason and this one's
throughout the tradition you know
Aristotle himself will do this in the
nick of McKean ethics in other places
you'll see Thomas Aquinas doing this
you're gonna see can't you know sort of
repeating this other people as well out
of his time and Hegel is going to work
with with this as well but for Hegel he
wants to get away from this this
bifurcation that often occurs in reason
because it's not as if we actually do
have two different faculties of reason
or two different you know radically
different ways of being rational so what
am I talking about here so on the one
hand people will talk about theoretical
or speculative or to use cos term pure
reason like you're thinking about his
first critique on the other hand people
will talk about practical reason and
Aristotle in the nicob McCann ethics
frames in terms of two different
modalities of truth there is truth you
know the truth that we think of when say
an expression tells you how things
actually are you know saying that my tie
is indeed tied around my neck or
something like that right dr. Sandler is
six foot three inches tall and then
there's practical reason and that is
concerned with truth but truth in a
different way Aristotle talks about this
as truth in
action truth in terms of rightly
oriented desire and one of the things
that we we see throughout the history of
thought is that philosophers tended to
be much more interested in working out
and working with theoretical or
speculative or our pure reason now
there's a problem with that because
practical reason is in a certain sense
what connects us more closely with the
world and ourselves because we exist
through action we do with the we do
think right the thinking itself is an
action so if you don't have some way of
connecting these two together you know
Thomas Aquinas will we'll talk in terms
of analogies between how theoretical
reason works you know using st.
syllogisms or things like that and then
how practical reason works as well but
it's all kind of easy isn't it and it
doesn't effectively capture not only
what goes on in our own day-to-day
practical reasoning but how this whole
world historical process which has
generated so many things operated on the
basis of a developing further and
further you know unfolding itself
rationality you know when we think about
history we shouldn't think on the one
hand that everybody was just like
ourselves except wearing different
costumes you know and stuck in different
social relations on the other hand
they're not radically distinct from us
in being so completely different that we
can't relate to them and understand that
they were rational beings as well
engaged in reasoning about things I mean
all you need to do for evidence about
this is is read some of the great
ancient authors I suggest reading
epictetus its discourses and you'll see
a lot of discussion of how rationality
worse on a practical basis from him now
all that set
notice what you're not seeing here
Hinkle does not begin by saying first
I'm going to treat pure reason because
cop did that but one of con successors a
little tree practical reason and steady
ties in terms of observing reason though
baktun reason actualization or if your
verily the rational self consciousness
through itself now then finally
individuality which is real in and for
itself you can if you want to identify
the very first section first part of
reason
observing reason with this you know
conception of theoretical reasons right
because a lot of what Hegel is going to
do if we look at the section headings
and content we have started with with an
observation of nature description laws
observation of the organic now it's
already starting to get a little bit
tricky I mean how do you observe living
things teleology although that seems to
be more or less within the realm of the
theatre radical or the speculative
dealing with things that are right and
making claims about that then we did to
the observation of self-consciousness in
its purity and its relation to external
actuality logical and psychological ones
how the human being reflects upon him or
herself and other human beings as
rational beings making sense of their
own reasoning processes now they were
already starting to see some practical
implications finally when we get to the
third portion of that observation of
self-consciousness in its relation to
its immediate actuality and we have this
in infamous section on phrenology you
know figuring out you know who people
are what their character is by the bumps
on their head which by the way Hegel is
not advocating I don't want to make that
clear from the start he was not a fan of
phrenology he's critiquing it here there
we go we start to see some practical
implications don't we so it's not just
pure reason that's going
observing reason but there is a
predominance there then in that section
this actualization of rational
self-consciousness what are the the
things the dialectics that were going
through pleasure and necessity the law
on the hurt and the frenzy of self
conceit virtue in the way of the world
these sound very much like they are
concerned with the practical sphere our
our emotions our decisions about things
in the world how we relate ourselves to
to other people and to the objects of
our desire all of that appears to be in
a matter of practical reason what we
wanted to avoid is thinking that somehow
practical reason is totally cut off from
any sort of theoretical implications on
the final part individuality which is in
for itself we have this introduction of
the spiritual the animal kingdom which
we'll get to very far down the lines
wonderful section seat the matter at
hand reason as lawgiver reason as
testing laws and when we're dealing with
that you know as cut did it very well
point out to us but he's only he's
really just saying something that in
this respect that Thomas Aquinas himself
already said and other people before him
said it in somewhat implicit or less
explicit ways like I'm thinking about
ants um for example reason involves you
know this this activity of either
ratifying or following or recognizing
laws and it does so both in terms of
what we could call laws governing what
we observe and laws then we should
operate according to so you know
speculative and practical if you like
but there's there's a same general
conception of law under girding all of
these in connecting them together maybe
an analogical concept not a univocal
concept but it is some same general
thing so in each of these we're going to
see theoretically and
practical reason being worked out it's
very important to remember as well Hagel
does not think that the human being and
as such simply possesses exactly the
same endowment of Reason at one given
time as in another or even within the
same culture occupying different roles
or different different places a lot of
that depends on development he does not
take reason he has something that you
can just assume everybody has the same
level of actuality or development of so
that's an upset about that such now
let's actually get into the paragraphs
in grasping the thought that the single
individual consciousness is in itself
absolute essence consciousness has
returned into itself for the unhappy
consciousness the in itself is the
beyond of itself but it's movement has
resulted in positing the completely
developed single individual or the
single individual that is an actual
consciousness as the negative of itself
that is as the objective extreme in
other words it is successfully struggled
to divest itself of its being for self
and has turned it into mere being in
this movement it has also become aware
of its unity with this universal a unity
which for us no longer falls outside of
it since the superseded in single
individual is the universal and which
since consciousness maintains itself in
this its negativity is present in
consciousness as such as its essence its
truth is that which appears in the
syllogism whose extremes appear it is
held absolutely asunder as the middle
term which proclaims to the unchangeable
consciousness that the single individual
has renounced itself and to the
individual that the unchangeable is for
it no longer an extreme but is
reconciled with it this middle term is
the unity directly aware of both and
connecting them and is the consciousness
of their unity which it proclaims the
consciousness and thereby to itself the
consciousness of the certainty of being
all truth
as we begin this this massive section
then with paragraph 231 let's remember
because that's what Hegel is doing for
us reminding us then we just emerged
from the unhappy consciousness and in
London happy consciousness we arrived at
this point where the importance of the
mediator has a kind of unifying or you
know imparting points within
consciousness but not truly realized as
consciousness was was was positive and
positive as a mediating you know term as
Hegel says in a syllogism between two
extremes a single individual extreme and
the as he called it the unchangeable as
he's calling it here absolute essence or
as he said over and over again the
universal so what's going on and says
you're asking the thought that the
single individual consciousness is in
itself absolute essence so somehow
there's you know there's there's an
identity going on here it's not just
that this is way over here this is over
here there's the mediator in between
doing what he or she or it does maybe
taking a little bit off to the the top
and you know continuing to have it it's
important that in that role instead of
mediator you might say in certain ways
is going to drop out because the single
individual is in fact identified wit of
the the at the absolute essence so I
says for the only happy consciousness
the in itself is the beyond in itself
this over here is what was not realize
is really being what one is and I want
you we should say here at this point as
well that it's not just only what one as
the single individual is what every
other single individual is as well so if
this is God then I am God but so is that
guy over there and so is that person
behind the camera and you know so on and
so forth right
whatever we're picking as the the
universal so he says you know this
movement is resulted in the completely
developed single individual or the
single individual that is an actual
consciousness that was the progress that
was made there and as the negative of
itself is able to contain negativity it
treats itself as the objective extreme
but as we saw when it's doing that it's
also behaving as a subject it can't make
itself solely into a thing and push
subjectivity off on this side because
it's acting as a subject in doing so and
when when it finally gets that that's
when we have a transition point here so
he says it's become aware of its unity
with this universal right the unity
which for us is no longer falls outside
of it since the superseded single
individual is the universal which sense
consciousness maintains itself in this
is present in consciousness it is
consciousness and that you know in which
let's say consciousness in which this
schism or division had taken place it is
within consciousness that the mediator
appears although it appears to the
individuals as if the mediator is
something else and so we have this
entire beyond over here but really the
unhappy consciousness has been
constituting all of this itself now
we're we have a transition and instead
of having the mediator remaining in
place what we have is the consciousness
of unity right what's left of the
mediator you could say is still
mediating by doing this it's telling the
absolute essence that the individual has
renounced itself that it's not just
being a bare individual you know
disconnected from the absolute essence
but in a certain way it is the absolute
essence on the other hand it's
proclaiming to the single individual
that the unchangeable has become
reconciled with it now who is this
meteor this is
it's really interesting the mediator is
now in this case the single individual
not every single individual because
they're still historically going to be
plenty of people who are you know
approaching the unchangeable the the
universal through the mediation of a
counselor a priest a minister a king you
know whoever whoever is the go betrayed
the Philosopher's perhaps but in this
case it's possible for the single
individual to realize him or herself
that they are because they aren't
consciousness they are this unity and
what that means is like Hegel is going
to say that they are this certainty of
being all truth this is a very radical
thing to say that the this is one thing
to say that you know whatever the
universal is you know the universal law
of universal whether it's the form of
the good whether it's you know mind
thinking itself whether it's you know
God has traditionally conceived whether
who knows you know the world process one
thing to say that that is certainty of
being all truth it's a whole nother
ballgame to say that the individual
realizes somehow that they have a
certainty of being all truth and what
could this possibly mean how how would
we get past the paradoxes that this is
going to introduce well you know as
usual with Hegel it's not only going to
happen at once there's gonna get process
of slowly uncovering and exploring these
things that is the way the negative
works but now the negative it has been
completely encompassed within the scope
of consciousness
now that self-consciousness is reason
its hitherto negative relation to other
nester ng's round into a positive
relation up till now it has been
concerned only with its independence and
freedom concern to save and maintain
itself for itself at the expense of the
world or of its own actuality both of
which appear to it as the negative of
its essence
but as reason assured of itself is at
peace with them and can endure them for
it is certain that it is itself reality
or that everything actual is none other
than itself it's thinking as itself
directly actuality and thus its
relationship to the latter is that of
idealism apprehending itself in this way
it is as if the world had for it only
now come into being
previously it did not understand the
world it desired it and worked on it
withdrew from it into itself and
abolished it as an existence on its own
account in its own self qua
consciousness both as consciousness of
the world as essence and as
consciousness of its nothingness in thus
apprehending itself after losing the
grave of its truth after the abolition
of its actuality is itself abolished and
after the singleness of consciousness is
for it in itself absolute essence it
discovers the world as its real world
which in its permanence holds an
interest for it which previously lay
only in its transiency for the existence
of the world becomes for self
consciousness its own truth and presence
it is certain of experiencing only
itself there
here in paragraph 232 just the second
paragraph in this new section Hale is
going to drop a terminological bomb on
us in talking about idealism and what I
what I want to say here is several
things one is we're going to talk a lot
about the nature of idealism as we
explore these other paragraphs to come
so we don't have to try to figure it all
out right now with respect to this
paragraph but Hegel is going to tell us
something really important about another
thing I want to say is that we've gotten
to the point in our use of this term
where too many people when they hear
idealism it connotes a kind of fuzzy
headedness sentimentality optimism
looking you know giving people the
benefit of the doubt
Hegel's not talking about that at all
the other thing to say is that for
people who remember these sort of older
every philosophical use of the term it's
very important not to identify Hinkle's
version of idealism with other people's
versions of idealism which angle is
going to take pains to critique and
distance himself from so you know if you
understand idealism along the lines of
berkeley or even can't that's not the
same thing as what the Eagle is
proposing and what you're going to see
as hinkel's idealism you have to see by
it by going through the process of of
each of these paragraphs and
understanding what it is that he's
getting at so I'll put an idealism on
the board in just a moment I want to say
that it doesn't matter where I put it on
the board or I didn't put it on the
board but hold on to that thought for
for just a moment you'll see exactly why
Hegel is now considering this question
of you know is is the relationship
between self-consciousness which is now
understood itself as reason right so
self-consciousness in its fullest sense
it is reason is its relationship to the
other to all tyranny to you know what
we've seen over and over again being
central to it in the standing
is essentially a negative relationship
or is it a positive relationship yeah in
the past it has been primarily a
negative relationship that's nice way to
get out in talking about the other
things that I have on the board and the
other things that are the paragraph the
cost that the person doesn't want to pay
what's going on in reason is a shift to
a positive relationship towards Altera
days they shouldn't just cancel it up
and I couldn't resist negating the
negation right it's going to happen is
this is actually transformed this is the
table right as we move from one one
stage is stall to another - all but the
negative is being transformed into a
positive relation with the other how is
it happening
well we're gonna see that playing itself
out let's let's see what the negative
relationship was first so he says you
know self-consciousness was so concerned
with its independence and it's created
it had a desire for independence and
freedom neither of which it totally ever
enjoyed it at any given point I mean it
would he have a limited amount of
Independence and then realize that that
independence was itself conditioned in
dependency to something else or that
well you know sort of expiration date
likewise with freedom you know when you
would you know have an advance and
realize I'm free and then suddenly the
another perspective would open up and
realize it wasn't as free as it thought
but what's important here is that in
order to try to preserve its
independence and freedom
it turns against two things it's only
actuality Hegel says its own the vehicle
e-type and what does he mean by a
vehicle impact let's remind ourselves
when we're talking about the individual
we're talking about the contingent
existence that continues the contingent
actions the contingent desires the work
the even the giving of thanks of the
individual existing in time place
culture you know with its
characteristics
it turns against that and we've seen
this happen in multiple different ways
it also turns against the world so it
doesn't just turn against a portion
itself it turns against the rest of
what's happening the world includes not
only objects like try and chalkboards or
the clothes that I'm wearing but other
people other self consciousnesses this
is very important and it doesn't want to
be the cost for either of these well
what is their cost turns out it doesn't
actually have to pay any cost because it
doesn't have to make a choice that I had
to make between independence and freedom
and having actuality and encountering
the world so he says as reason assured
of itself it is at peace with that this
is a process this this becoming reason
this this rationalization this is a
process not only as Hegel's call it
reconciliation but we might call it
reintegration of the human person so he
says because it's certain its itself
reality or that everything actual is
none other than itself it's thinking it
is itself directly actuality it is able
to be a peace with them and can endure
them and here's where he says its
relationship to actuality actuality in
terms of the world actuality in terms of
itself is that idealism what does
idealism mean you know some people want
to say idealism means that everything
that exists is just in our minds and you
know in a certain sense okay that's
that's you know ideas in our minds I get
where people are coming from with that
every real idealist has never said that
it's just a matter of ideas there's also
explaining you know sort of what's
what's beneath the ideas but it's a
starting point another way of looking at
idealism is
to sort of turn it outward and saying
the world that we are experiencing and
the world within us is within our
consciousness so it's not something
radically foreign and other never
graspable by our consciousness insofar
as it is for consciousness it has what
being it has may not be that we are
consciousness of it is entirely adequate
at this point the idealist doesn't have
to claim that it is but what he was
saying is that reason rationality as an
active power as the way that a person is
engaging the world understanding
themselves understanding their relations
with others understanding the social
world represents an incredible optimism
that things that the world is knowable
because the world is for it now what
does that mean he goes on and he says
apprehending itself in this way because
it understands itself differently it is
as if the world had for it only now come
into being isn't that a marvelous way of
putting it what is taken to be the world
up to this point was not really the
world it's only able once it feels
secure enough to trust the world and and
to say the world is not going to get to
you know swamp me because it's other
only then it is the person able to grasp
the real or an actual world
move your Gleek world as it is he says
previously it did not understand the
world it desired it it worked on it
withdrew from it into itself abolished
it as an existence on its own account
it's on self consciousness and we can go
on you know we don't have to go through
all the examples it is giving it but the
point is in its engagement with the
world in consciousness and
particularly with self-consciousness it
was not fully understanding what world
is and it took it as as threatening its
own independence and and freedom to be
entangled with the world was dangerous
and even to be entangled with one's own
contingency was likewise dangerous and
so we saw these different ways of trying
to get past that you know stoicism
skepticism the unhappy consciousness are
three particularly at least for a little
while successful and then radically
unsuccessful ways of attempting that
according to Hegel so he goes on and he
says after the singleness of
consciousness is for itself absolute
essence it discovers the world as its
new world I should have put it not just
new real or actual world it's very
important here as Hegel is saying that
it realizes that this is its real new
world that the world is for it that it's
not something that the individual is
totally estranged from so he goes on and
he says it discovers the world is new
real world which in its permanence holds
an interest for it which previously lay
only in its transiency for the existence
of the world becomes her
self-consciousness its own truth and
presence this is part of what we're
getting at and Hegel's form of idealism
the world yes for self consciousness is
for reason it is part of its scope so
you could say that on the one hand
you've got the individual has just one
thing in the world but the individual is
also you might say the center of the
world in a certain way this raises some
problems which we're going to see come
up later I'm you know about what
than multiple centers but we don't need
to worry about that quite yet let's sort
of linger over this achievement at the
very beginning of this brand-new session